you're doing something that you don't
want to do so you want to postpone it I
am asking why the hell are you doing
something that you don't want to do even
if you put through the most horrible
situations either you can come out using
that experience is a better human being
or you can use the experience to become
a horrible mess nobody can cause mental
pain to you it is you in reaction to
something that happens around you that
you caused pain to yourself leave
motivation
he's sadguru and here's my take on his
top ten rules a success vol 5 and joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one do what you want so yeah if you're
postponing something you're obviously
doing something that you don't want to
do if there is something that you really
want to do will you postpone it or pre
pon it hello
do you see somebody is waiting for
someone they badly want to see only ten
minutes in the ten minutes they will
look at the watch 25 times why they want
to propone it you're doing something
that you don't want to do so you want to
postpone it I am asking why the hell are
you doing something that you don't want
to do no because if I do this I will get
that I will get that that's not the
point there is nothing to get in this
life this is really nothing to get in
this life either you live this life in a
profound and intense manner or you did
not what will you get in the end if
somebody dies in the Agricultural
College do they bury them or fire them
how is it
what's the tradition burying is good for
agriculture because human beings make
good manure so in the end what will
happen to you and me they will either
barriers or Burness that's all will
happen in the end you think something
else they'll give you a price nothing
will happen in the end only thing is the
process of life how wonderfully did you
live that's all there is so if you are
doing something really wonderful do you
want to pre pawn it or postpone it
proponent so you must find what is it
that you really want to do if you find
that one thing you will always propone
everything not postpone rule number two
become wise this happened in 1941 this
is just when the Nazi moment was
building up in Germany and in some parts
of Europe so one day in Austria a bunch
of German soldiers came broke into the
homes the Jewish family a rich family
they broke the home and took away the
adults took everything was robbed and
these two children a 12 year old girl
and a 8 year old boy were taken away
they were taken to a railway station
this amount of number n December kind of
time when he's becoming very cold so
they were kept in the railway station
for three days because the trains did
not come boys little boys being boys
they started playing football so they
were playing football and then suddenly
the train came the train is not a
passenger train it's a cargo train the
goods train so when the train came the
soldiers came and rushed everybody into
the the wagons which are there everybody
got in and the little boy and the girl
also got in but the little boy forgot to
wear his shoes he left his shoes outside
and they pushed him into the wagon so
without shoes he came his sister a
twelve-year-old girl saw her kid brother
coming without shoes and she got mad
with him she held him by the year boxed
his ears scolded him nicely he slapped
them say you idiot already we are in
enough trouble
now you come without shoes because in
Germany in winter no shoes means you may
lose your feet so she's angry about that
in the next station the boys and girls
were separated after four years after
the war was over she came out of the
concentration camp to find 17 members of
family including her little brother all
had vanished no records no sign of them
they just evaporated at that time the
only thing that bothered her was the
last few things that she said to her
little brother she loves her brother but
the last few things that she said to him
for such terrible things it rang in her
mind and troubled her these are the last
things I told my brother and after that
I'm never going to see him he's gone so
she took a vow if I speak to anybody in
my life I will speak in such a way if
this is my last word I will not regret
this one thing transformed her life in
such a way she went on to United States
she died in 2006 she did some phenomenal
work built a hospital somewhere near
Chicago I think she lived a fruitful
life I'm saying even if you put through
the most horrible situations either you
can come out using that experience as a
better human being or you can use the
experience to become a horrible mess so
whenever something hurts you there are
two options you can either become
wounded or you can become wise this is
the choice the more things hurt you
early on in your life the wiser you
should have become isn't it but
unfortunately most people become wounded
this is simply because they just need an
excuse to turn their own intelligence
against themselves
that's all especially if the world
around you turns against you is it not
very very important that your
intelligence stands up for you
rule number three control your mind
around us so many people will do so many
things that we don't like yes or no so
many things in Mumbai happening things
that we don't like that every day happen
but at least within you
only what you want should happen within
this isn't it huh I cannot decide that
only what I want should happen with you
but I can definitely decide only what I
want must happen within me isn't it if
you could decide only what you want
should happen within you would you
choose anger or joy what's your choice
please choose I'm going to bless you see
you want the highest level of
pleasantness for yourself isn't it then
why is such a thing not happening as I
said earlier you never read the user's
manual how this functions has not been
looked at do not go by the example of
people who came here a few few years
earlier than you that no no my mother
also has like that my grandmother also
was getting angry so I am also getting
angry they should not be the leading
lights of your life I want you to look
at it your thought your emotion your
body must happen the way you want isn't
it if somebody else can decide what
should happen within you this is
ultimate slavery isn't it so what
happens around you maybe we can decide
but nobody should decide except yourself
what happens within you if you decide
you would keep this in the highest state
of pleasantness for sure you wouldn't be
battling with anger it's not just about
anger fear stress tension don't address
them separately essentially your mind is
not taking instructions from you why
because you don't know where the damn
keyboard is yet
we gave you a supercomputer you do not
know where where the keyboard is so one
day you did this something work another
day you did this something work you know
have you seen people the radio doesn't
work boom and it works sometimes
that's another technology that's chance
have you seen this if something doesn't
work people think top top top it'll work
and a lot of people are using this for
human beings also rule number four work
on your own well-being the fear of
suffering is not just about pain the
fear of suffering is self-inflicted
nobody can cause mental pain to you it
is you in reaction to something that
happens around you that you cause pain
to yourself if you have half your brain
removed then you would see you would be
quite peaceful right now people are
going through stress anxiety depression
misery all kinds of things you can give
it any number of exotic names that you
want but essentially their intelligence
is turned against them that's all it is
once your intelligence is against you
there is no force on the planet or
anywhere which can save you so the
fundamental thing is to bring this that
all the faculties that we have should
work for our well-being
right now our own body our own mind our
own emotions are working against us this
one thing has to be fixed this is the
machine also if you want to learn how to
have more confidence check out my 254
series the link is free and it's in the
description below it's easy to make a
buck very hard to make a difference to
make changes in any organization you
have to have a measure of very high
persistency you have to work with people
where you feel a bit insecure that's
essential because that means you're
working with people who are better than
you rule number five study your opponent
this happened in the 98 99
Andrea Gussie and Boris Becker played
three games all Boris Becker beat Andrea
Ghazi because he had such a you know he
was called boom-boom because Boris
Becker called boom-boom because of the
service his Serbs were so powerful there
was no game
every time he will serve serve and
finish the game nobody returns the ball
so Andre Agassi went back and studied
hundreds of hours of Boris Becker's
serves then he figured it out then in
the next three years he played 11 games
with him and beat him on 10 of them I'll
tell you what happened after Boris
Becker retired they met in Germany
there's something called the Oktoberfest
in Germany they were there and at that
time they were together and then dragged
as he thought okay anyway he's retired
now I can tell him because this bothered
Boris pick a big time nobody can beat
him but this guy's getting at him so he
told him see I observed your videos
continuously and I figured out that
whenever you are serving the ball
towards the boundary line Boris Becker
if you know when he's serving his tongue
sticks out a little bit when he throws
the ball up and comes down his tongue
sticks out said whenever you're serving
towards the boundary line your tongue
goes to the left when you're serving
straight it comes out straight I
observed this the moment your tongue
sticks out to the boundary line I was
already there every time taking the ball
so Boris Becker literally fell off his
chair he couldn't believe this and he
said any number of times I went home
after the matches and I told my wife he
seems to be reading my mind but you've
been reading my tongue
it's almost spoken so your opponent
should be never unfamiliar to you you
must make him familiar you must know him
better than he knows himself rule number
six make life better
this is to be a little context we saw
the video said received an email yes
people indicate that in that context how
do you keep yourself on the move all the
time on the copy you don't have to be on
the go all the time
if life demands people ask me so true
how are you active like it's because
generally my schedule is anywhere
between 18 to 20 hours a day seven days
of the week 365 days non-stop for many
years it's going on I'm complaining and
the guys clapping about it so people
keep asking how do you keep yourself
like this how do you do this
see I'm essentially lazy it's just that
the situation in the world demands
action left to myself I would close my
eyes and simply said I made like this if
I close my eyes I can sit like this till
I fall dead really I have really no need
for action I'm not trying to keep myself
busy there's a lot to be done so you're
doing people ask me such guru what's
your dream what is your dream
I said my dream is the day I am
unemployed that's a great day because if
I am unemployed
it simply means everybody is doing
fantastic what more do you want
dream fulfilled so action is not
something that you decide you just
decide your intent action the world will
decide how much of what I am you know at
these Economic Forum's instead I am at
the World Economic Forum this guy from
business schools in Howard Business
School one professor comes oh you're
that amazing tree planter I said no I am
NOT a tree planter
you sure no no you planted those
millions of teeth yes I did but I am NOT
a tree planter then what do you do I
said I make people flower not plain
trees but I'm planting trees because the
goddamn trees are missing where they
should have been where they should have
been they are not there it's like this
two men were working on the street
one man is digging pits behind him
another man is coming and closing and
closing and going somebody else was
driving by they saw this ridiculous
activity one guy digs the pit another
guy closes the pit so they stopped and
said hey what are you doing here why you
guys working like this one guy digging
another at closing they said no no the
in-between guy has gone and leave he is
the tree planter he's not there we're
doing our work so a lot of people are
doing work like I am doing my work you
have no work on this planet the planet
needs work if the world needs work we
will do it otherwise why should I think
this is my work so it's good what's your
mission
it's an omission I'm just fooling around
a bit because you have no business to
have your own mission life has its own
mission in some way if you can assist
and serve that that's about it what is
it that you have your own mission are
you some kind of a tyrant all
machineries are tyrants in some way
unknowingly yes those who think they
have a mission there is no mission what
is needed you do especially when you
study in a business school and get
certain competence to manage things or
create things you must create what is
needed not create some rubbish and push
it on them yes yes or no you may see how
to make life better how to solve
situations which are problematic to a
whole lot of people you must look for
solutions and solutions for the existing
situations and of course there are
experts who go on
creating new problems so you will never
be short of problems believe me you just
have to create solutions not go on a
mission mode that's for Mussolini rule
number seven take control of your life
what people are generally calling as
destiny is essentially what they end up
creating unconsciously when I say
unconsciously as you sit here right now
as everybody sits here right now
there is physical activity going on
within the system there is mental
process there is emotional activity and
of course the life energies are active
every moment they are taking in hundreds
of inputs whether you're conscious are
not conscious so if I ask you a question
since this morning from the time you
woke up till now of these four
dimensions of activity how much have you
conducted consciously what percentage do
you think few things how much percentage
do you think 25% you're very generous
man
it's well below 1% if you walk from
there to there there will be 25
different kind of smells that you're not
conscious of but the body registers and
records there are 100 different kinds of
sounds the body registers that you are
not conscious of like this throughout
the day and night in wakefulness and
sleep this is happening when you are
only conscious of less than 1% of your
activity definitely life will look like
an accident
hello when 99% of the things that you're
doing you're doing unconsciously
definitely life look will look
accidental if the accident see it is so
happened somebody fell off on the street
and had a brain injury after that
suddenly they started working their
mathematics in a wonderful way but that
was only one a thousand other people who
cracked their skull
never recovered from that or they died
or those who lived on lived on much
diminished so being accidentally
fortunate is not the way to exist
so whenever a pleasant accident happens
we say it's destiny some of you even say
God doing things to me when did you make
a partnership with him I don't know
so shall I tell you a story ok
this happened Sherlock Holmes
you know Sherlock Holmes and Watson went
out camping and early morning 3:30 a.m.
Sherlock Holmes nudged Watson the open
is nice what what do you see
he asked well I see a clear sky and
stars what does that mean to you he said
well that means tomorrow is going to be
a wonderful sunny day yes what does it
mean to you that it means someone has
told in our tent so we don't know what
went missing and something may fall here
and there by chance but that's not the
way life works if a human being doesn't
take it upon himself or herself to make
their own destiny they're still having
an evolutionary problem that is they are
still not yet fully deaf because being
human means this that we can conduct our
life consciously
being human means this that we can craft
our life the way we want but this
destiny business is a good insurance to
handle your failure whenever you fail
destiny so God's will rule number 8
become the-best-version-of-yourself just
because somebody is successful
this doesn't mean they've figured out
everything this doesn't mean they're at
ease with life this doesn't mean their
life is in some way fulfilled no because
today our idea of success is just doing
little better than somebody else you
doing little better than somebody else
means and you're very happy
that what it means is you're actually
enjoying other people's failures if
somebody enjoys another person's failure
I call that sickness not success what do
you call it hello I enjoy that you
failed this is sickness this is not
success isn't it unfortunately this is
half your coin this is the reason why
human potential is not unleashed because
if you are racing with a lame person you
just happy you're one step ahead of him
only when you meet missile Bold you
understand who the hell you are
yes till then you think you are a great
runner because other person doesn't have
legs rule number nine don't fear
suffering you did this activity where to
get us awake and energized you had us
close our eyes and you count to three
and then we had to yell lose our
inhibitions and and let it all out and
that idea of kind of losing control
losing traditions for me personally has
actually been a challenge and I was
hoping to get your perspective I have
never done drugs because I don't want to
lose control
I fight roller coasters because I don't
like losing control their body I'm
excited for your perspective I don't
know why it it came up because last
night I did my best but it's always been
a challenge or a struggle for me and I'm
just curious to get your perspective
nature has imposed substantial amount of
restrictions on life
you can just zoom out into the space
there is enough restrictions you don't
have to invent your own restrictions on
top of it so if you invent your own
restrictions slowly over a period of
time you become a constipated life that
means life won't happen easy it happens
in small happenings so being in a state
of abandoned not out of control being in
a state of abandoned means all the
stuffs that you have put on yourself you
pulled it off
native stops are still there there for
your safety and your well-being but why
are you imposing stops there's enough
gravity is holding you down that's bad
enough now you want to hold yourself
down why because fear what is the fear
about the fear is always about if I do
this I may suffer so that is a
fundamental of my work to bring you to
your place where there's no fear of
suffering and rule number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
get drunk on life as a child did you
blow so bubbles so bubbles so when you
blew so bubbles
have you seen somebody got this big
bubble you got only this big bubble we
must hold our breath and leave it slow
then we get a big bubble
everybody had air in the lungs but
somebody got a big bubble somebody got a
small bubble what is this about see when
it comes to body this is my body that is
your body hundred percent clear no
confusion about this isn't it this is my
body that is your body this is my mind
that is your mind but when it comes to
life there is no such thing as my life
and your life
this is a living cosmos how much life
will you capture within your system will
determine the size and scope of your
life somebody got a big bubble somebody
else got a small bother OOP it went off
you cannot identify where is my air and
where is your air is something so
similarly when it comes to life there is
no such thing as my life and your life
but distinctly my body and your body my
mind and your mind but no my life and
your life there is life abundant life
this is a living cosmos how much life
will you capture within yourself will
determine the scope and range of your
life what one person can do in 100 years
somebody may do it in 10 years because
of the sheer intensity of life when I
say intensity of life it may translate
in many different ways
see there are times for example certain
businesses have grown let us say some
business like you know in United States
has become a fad
within three years somebody's billions
of dollars of worth of business let us
say Microsoft has grown or Facebook has
grown or something like this has grown
this is largely because of technological
breakthroughs and somebody writes that
technology at another time that would
not have happened so that is different
but if you want to create something
really large really significant larger
small is not the point
significance then you need intensity of
life one thing is the scale of life that
you capture there are this is what I
said earlier when I said yoga
obliterating in boundaries of the
duality means in a way you are allowing
universe to invade you when universe is
not against you but it invades you or
it's a part of you then you have
abundance of life when you have
abundance of life you will not hesitate
to share when you share big time your
life with everybody else people will
naturally value it immensely because
everybody is trying to hold it somebody
is willing to share it so naturally
there will be a big upsurge around you
this will lead to many things this will
make many friends and many enemies a lot
of people whom you have never met there
your sown enemies but you don't know why
you never met them you never had a word
with them but they are swearing that I
am his enemy
I don't know why but it goes on in the
world so when we talk about how so much
can be done in a short span of time it's
not a short span of time he's 37 years
incessant work seven days of the week 20
hours a day almost for 25 years more
than 25 years on an everyday I slept
only for 2 and a half hours a day not
deprived of sleep just kept my life
energy so intense that sleep was not
even an issue there are times when I
have gone without sleep for 3 days 4
days full scale working not because
you're on some kind of a drug and not
sleeping simply because of the intensity
of purpose and commitment to what you're
doing today I can proudly say I have
created thousands of people around me
all of them have gotten crazy like that
they are beginning to work like this
most of them you don't know when they
will sleep
when they will wake up on on on seven
days of the week no holidays no
vacations but everybody's joyful if you
come to the yoga center and see you will
see the most joyful faces but they've
never been on a vacation they don't want
a damn thing they don't have money in
their pockets but they're just joyful
because drunk with life literally now
I've got a special bonus clip from
Sadhguru on how to not live life too
early that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching a video to taking action
here we go question number one
where do you need to take control of
your life number two what suffering do
you need to stop fearing and number
three how can you get drunk on life this
week in India the mango farmers have
some wisdom and them like this I've been
a mango farmer in the past just after 12
14 months after planting if it's a well
grafted plant within 14 months flowers
will come when the season comes first
thing we do is we'll pluck off the
flowers if you leave it a few mangoes
will come but we will take it off next
season again the flowers come we'll take
it off we will wait for the plant to
grow because we know if the fruit comes
out of that plant that plant will never
grow into your full-fledged tree it will
not bear as much fruit as it could if it
bears too early so this is something
youth must remember don't try to live
too early this is the time where you
build yourself in body in mind in
competence in capability you build
yourself time to live will come if you
live too early then you will see you
will not live a full fledge life so
right now we have imported this from
Western societies by the time you're 14
you must have a boyfriend or a
girlfriend by the time you're acting 18
you have had three heartbreaks where the
hell are you focusing and building
yourself these things are taking so much
time and energy build yourself up Wells
if you want to live well so there is a
certain time to grow and there is a
certain time to live if you live too
early you will not grow and if you don't
grow the scale and scope of your life
will be very limited
if you want more sadguru check out the
first top ten rules video made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you cannot fight or you cannot
overcome that which does not exist we
have fixed too many things on the
outside